machtkampf in der afd
der rauswurf von brandenburgs landeschef
kalbitz wird für die kartei zur
zerreißprobe
proteste gegen korona maßnahmen
verfassungsschützer zeigen sich besorgt
über rechte einflussnahme in brasilien
steigen die korona infektion massiv an
es gibt fast 15.000 neue fälle an einem
tag
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
petra gerster guten abend willkommen zu
den nachrichten am sonntag in der afg
spitze fliegen die fetzen
der vorstand ist tief gespalten der
rechtsnationale partei flügel macht
front gegen parteichef leuten von verrat
ist die rede
fraktionschef kauder spricht heute im
zdf interview von einer zerreißprobe
der vorstand hatte in einer
kampfabstimmung auf antrag läutens den
brandenburgischen landeschef kalbitz
wegen möglicher früherer neonazi
verbindungen aus der partei
ausgeschlossen
andreas kühn als berichtet da kommt
ärger alexander gauland ist afd
ehrenvorsitzender und fraktionschef und
sehr wütend dass parteichef leuten den
brandenburger fdp chef aus der partei
wirft hält bauland für einen
riesenfehler politisch und rechtlich
fraktionschefs gegen parteichef angriff
in berlin direkt ich hatte es nicht für
möglich gehalten dass er einen solchen
beschlussvorschlag einbringt
ich habe mit ihm vorher darüber
gesprochen und habe ihm deutlich gesagt
dass ich das sehr kritisch sehe und dass
ich das niemals rechtlich verhallt
behalte aber er hat es dann trotzdem
gemacht die afg in aufruhr weil der
brandenburger parteichef kalbitz seine
rechtsextreme vorgeschichte verschwiegen
haben soll wirft ihnen der
bundesvorstand vor zwei tagen aus der
partei daraufhin kampfansage der kalbitz
freunde vom rechtsnationalen flügel
wer die argumente von partei gegnern
aufgreift und sie gegen parteifreunde
wendet der begeht verrat an der partei
konkret greift röcke parteichef leuten
und vize chefin von storch an diese zwei
wollten eine andere partei die antwort
nein es gehe allein um die eigenen
regeln
wer mitglied in einer militanten neonazi
organisation gewesen ist kann nicht
mitglied der afg sein das ist nichts
neues wir haben auch in der
vergangenheit so entschieden da kann der
bundesvorstand keine ausnahme machen
zum machtkampf kommt ein juristisches
problem kalbitz afd aufnahmeantrag ist
verschollen damit steht sein rauswurf
auf der kippe das gesamte interview mit
fdp-fraktionschef bauland können sie in
berlin direkt sehen gleich im anschluss
sachsens regierungschef kretschmann cdu
hat seine eigene partei aufgefordert den
widerstand gegen die grundrente
aufzugeben
der zuschlag auf kleine renten müssen
nun beschlossen werden und in kraft
treten sagte er der bild am sonntag
gerade für die menschen im osten sei das
wichtig vor allem der wirtschaftsflügel
der union hatte den koalitionskompromiss
zur grundrente zuletzt wieder in frage
gestellt und das mit den kosten der
korona krise begründet die große
mehrheit hierzulande steht hinter den
schutz maßnahmen der regierung gegen des
corona virus doch eine lautstarke
minderheit protestierte auch an diesem
wochenende vielerorts vehement gegen die
einschränkungen und das obwohl die doch
gerade überall gelockert werden
dabei rücken zunehmend auch
rechtsextremisten in den fokus von
verfassungsschutz und
sicherheitsbehörden david sauer
in schwerin wurde auch heute wieder
demonstriert gegen die regierung
hygienemaßnahmen grundrechts
beschränkungen sowie zuletzt in vielen
städten neben bürgerlichen demonstranten
sind dabei auch angst mache
antisemiten erzähler von angeblicher
impfpflicht und geheime weltregierung
außerdem politisch extreme die versuchen
die proteste zu vereinnahmen warnt der
verfassungsschutz
[Applaus]
es besteht die gefahr dass
rechtsextremisten sich mit ihren
feindbildern und starts zu setzenden
zielen an die spitze der kroner
demonstrationen stellen die aktuell
mehrheitlich von verfassungstreue
bürgern durchgeführt werden
dabei gehen die extremisten nach einem
bekannten muster vor beobachtete
vorsitzende der innenministerkonferenz
das eine ganz bestimmte strategie
dahinter steckt eben die sogenannte
entgrenzung versuchen rechtsextremisten
in weite teile der gesellschaft
sympathien zu erwerben vorzudringen und
das ist genau das was problematisches
nicht selten wird dabei das
gewaltmonopol des staates in frage
gestellt gedankengut aus den filter
blasen des internets entlädt sich in der
realen welt rechte und linke tragen ihre
emotionen auf die straße so wie gestern
in frankfurt wo die polizei mühe hatte
die gruppen auseinanderzuhalten
die gewalt und das verschwimmen der
grenze zwischen gemäßigten und extremen
das bringt legitimen protest gegen
grundrechts beschränkungen in misskredit
schauen wir auf die aktuellen zahlen in
deutschland da gehen die neuinfektionen
weiter nach unten
im durchschnitt der vergangenen woche
steckten sich 630 menschen pro tag mit
dem corona virus an der niedrigste wert
seit zwei monaten
insgesamt sind mehr als 176.000
infektion durch tests bestätigt rund 100
54.000 erkrankte gelten als genesen 7
1958 menschen starben in verbindung mit
coop 19
in brasilien hingegen breitet sich das
virus weiter dramatisch aus allein in
den letzten 24 stunden gab es was 15.000
neuinfektionen
insgesamt haben sich mehr als 233 1500
menschen angesteckt das ist inzwischen
der vierthöchste wert weltweit die zahl
der todesfälle liegt bei über 15.600
präsident bruce sohn aber bleibt bei
seinem kurs er spielt die gefahren durch
das virus noch immer herunter christoph
reckert
dort wo sonst nur boote hinkommen ist
das virus längst unterwegs ein
bestattungs boot auf dem weg in den
regenwald corona dringt immer weiter vor
zu den menschen die ihr abgeschieden
leben trägt masken um eure liebsten zu
schützen steht an der kirche
krankenhäuser gibt es hier nicht die 86
jährige frau war schwer krank klagte
über atemnot dann startet sie kam in
einem schlechten zustand zu uns und
erlitt einen herzstillstand wir haben
versucht sie wiederzubeleben ohne erfolg
ob es wirklich corona ist wissen wir
noch nicht wir haben keinen test noch
immer wird in brasilien viel zu wenig
getestet doch die sprunghaft gestiegene
zahl der beerdigung ist ein indiz dafür
dass die offiziellen zahlen weit
untertrieben sind experten schätzen dass
in wahrheit bis zu 20 mal so viele
menschen infiziert sind gestört wird der
kampf gegen das virus von ganz oben
präsident portion euro befindet sich in
einer politischen krise rund um
polizeiposten korruptionsvorwürfe einem
drohenden amtsenthebungsverfahren und
eben corona in dem chaos hat er jetzt
den zweiten gesundheitsminister verloren
vor allem zu berichten insider weil er
weiter einen wissenschaftlichen umgang
mit der krise und quarantänemaßnahmen
ablehnt stattdessen will er die
wirtschaft öffnen die ärzte den
überlasteten krankenhäusern wählen
müssen den sie behandeln und wen nicht
haben dafür kein verständnis
es ist schrecklich wenn die ärzte die
laster entscheidung tragen müssen wer
lebt und wer stirbt kein klares konzept
gegen korona kein ende in sicht
es sieht schlecht aus für brasilien mehr
als ein jahr lang herrschte praktisch
stillstand in der israelischen politik
drei parlamentswahlen hatten keine
eindeutige mehrheit gebracht doch jetzt
nach viel tauziehen steht eine
einheitsregierung mit einem deal likud
chef benjamin netanjahu bleibt für 18
weitere monate ministerpräsident dann
übernimmt der frühere armeechef benny
gantz das amt aus ehemaligen rivalen
müssen nun partner werden nicola
albrecht der alte und neue
premierminister benjamin netanyahu hat
es geschafft die regierung ist vereidigt
die große koalition mit seinem ex
rivalen benny gantz steht und es ist
eine sehr große koalition 34 minister
stellte netanjahu vor einige posten
wurden extra neu geschaffen
bereits am mittag demonstrieren bürger
vor allem selbstständige die durch
corona in wirtschaftliche not geraten
sind gegen dieses größte kabinett in der
geschichte des landes
diese aufgeblasene regierung wird den
bedürfnissen der jetzigen realität
überhaupt nicht gerecht seit zwei
monaten ist ja alles dicht
einheitsregierung nennen dagegen
netanjahu und ganz ihr bündnis unter dem
deckmantel die korona krise bestmöglich
zu managen und dem wohle der
gesellschaft zu dienen betreiben die
parteien und politiker hier vor allem
knallharte macht politik allen voran
premierminister netanjahu der sich über
die vergabe so viele posten seine
führungsposition gesichert und loyalität
erkauft hat und so kündigte netanjahu
gleich heute an schon bald eine seiner
umstrittensten wahlversprechen
umzusetzen die annexion einiger
jüdischer siedlungen im von israel
besetzten westjordanland
es ist zeit israelisches recht
anzuwenden und ein weiteres glorreiches
kapitel in der geschichte des zionismus
aufzuschlagen
doch zunächst wird sich netanjahu der
justiz stellen müssen kommenden sonntag
wird das strafverfahren wegen korruption
gegen ihn eröffnet ein amtierender
premier unter anklage noch ein novum in
der geschichte israels
auch heute wurde wieder fußball gespielt
bundesliga unter corona bedingungen
erster fc köln gegen mainz 05 das spiel
endete unentschieden 2 2
abstand halten bleibt er das oberste
gebot in diesen tagen auch beim
nationalfeiertag in norwegen in diesem
jahr anders als sonst aber nicht ohne
musik
weit oben auf dem holmenkol und unten
auf der straße mit kreativen
abstandshaltern nur bei der spritztour
der königsfamilie wurde es dann doch
etwas enger und wir haben noch die
gemischten wetteraussichten für sie
viele wolken gibt es morgen im nordosten
und da kann es auch mal regnen sonst
scheint oft die sonne im norden 13 bis
20 sonst sommerliche 20 bis 25 grad und
es wird noch wärme im laufe der woche so
viel
von uns für den moment mehr hat dann
marietta slomka im heute journal um
viertel vor ziehen
ich freue mich dass sie dabei waren und
hoffe sie morgen wieder zu sehen um 19
uhr